hey everyone Tom here welcome back to
watching the Watchmen this is a
infrequent podcast or myself and my
co-hosts are exploring all things
Watchmen not necessarily all things Alan
Moore Dave Givens John Higgins Watchmen
shout at them and Jay Higgs especially
check out the episode that we did quite
a few months ago now but yeah mostly
going through the classic graphic novel
but we're also looking at its sequel
it's a prequel the HBO adaption there's
loads of things going on and it's not
just myself man deaf as well deaf how's
it going what's happening everyone hope
you're having a lovely lovely
read-through of Doomsday Clock we all
are we've got a few things to get
through today you know we're gonna angry
X you have an email to read out which is
quite rare from one a few comments Tom
I'm just quickly trying to organize them
now right so I've got them I've got the
comments we're ready to go or we're
recording [ __ ] we're recording the green
light is going or the red light or
whatever this observer yeah but we're
close to midnight and before we get to
doomsday five let's talk a little bit
about I guess Watchmen news before we
get into the email as well as a lot of
people are aware Watchmen is coming to
HBO in some form although it's clear
from what's been released it's been
about a month or so since did our last
episodes there's been a big dump of
information that this isn't really
Watchmen I mean Lindelof says it's a
remixed version death yeah I don't know
it's gonna be like to be honest it's
Watchmen it would be better if they just
like made a TV show and then the twist
at the end of it was like oh [ __ ] it's
Watchmen yeah yeah it'd be like let
split the other year that did that they
just did a normal movie and then at the
end it turned out would be like an
unbreakable sequel that'd be great
and all that shitty Robert Pattinson
film from my 2008 where the twist is
that it takes place on 9/11 and the
final scene is like the tab you liked to
[ __ ] you feel I haven't seen that I
watch it tonight but there's nothing to
do with 9/11 the entire film then he
says oh yeah he was in the towers or
whatever but but yeah I don't really
understand I mean Lindelof shared
something on his Instagram he's one of
the most infuriating people to follow on
Instagram I would say he's got such of
weird me me sense of humor I don't
really like and it's like I do have
respect for Damon Lindelof in some sense
certainly on TV I think he has a lot of
ideas like have you have you ever seen
the leftovers I haven't no affair that's
really good no good actually yeah
started watching it the problem is I
started watching the first episode it's
quite mystery based and I thought to
myself [ __ ] yeah I'm just gonna read
what the ending is so I spoiled it
entirely I know where the two-percent go
it's actually quite a good ending I was
quite surprised how create if it wasn't
satisfying but did you even watch that
9/11 movie tour did you just spoil it I
just see it was a Robert Pattinson fan
it was oh wait we all were shower clips
but but yes so essentially I don't
remember that period Tom that well I
don't remember that I must have missed
that but but yeah The Watchmen TV show
is coming after left over so in lost
obviously Lindelof has a bit of a legacy
but yeah my fear is that it's gonna be a
bit like Doomsday Clock that we're
discussing today where it's gonna be a
lot of touchstones a lot of wink-wink
moments but you think yourself what's
really the point yeah I really don't
know it just sounds like it's gonna be
supplementary material and it's probably
gonna I'm sure they set a time period
was that taken place after watching as
well I mean I suppose I could give some
free rein to kind of do what they want
and it also means that they're not gonna
mess up their source material but I
don't I don't really care be honest
no no mean evil watchman doesn't need
sequels no no no it definitely doesn't
doesn't need prequels doesn't need
tie-in [ __ ] iPhone games that I think
that's the only committee before the
movie was like a side scroller where you
played as my Alan Ross I've watched a
YouTube video of it on their PlayStation
[Music]
it will be cool if on like the DC
fighting games you could play as like
Manhattan or Rorschach or something yeah
I mean hopefully Doomsday Clock kind of
shows that they're gonna maybe bring
them into into the the main universe and
put them and stuff like injustice they
might do a Lego game on them of judges
for Lego Lego Marvel of
of course you did of course stupid I
hate I hate the Lego games right but I'm
just so in the marvel at the moment that
I was just like oh you know what I'm
gonna do it my recent I recently bought
a tablet to read like stuff digitally
and I just found Marvel unlimited I
found out about them basically you pay
nine pound a month it sounds a bit like
an advert this doesn't it but you get em
you get access to basically millions of
comics all that's what the whole image
the whole archive is it yeah so I bought
a tablet to read that and because it's
just digital but I'm quite looking
forward to to going through everything
on that that's cool actually and yeah
especially cuz I run a comic book
website and it's very expensive to
constantly buy graphic novels no it ca
it is I feel kind of bad actually
because you know Oxford has one comic
book store where I live and I've
reserved Doomsday Clock and I keep
getting emails like every month like
issue free forum five in the top six is
it I'm not putting out 25 quid for this
crap I'm sorry I you know I'm not one
not willing to pay it ya know
I don't mind those Lego games because I
like Lego and I like seeing the designs
of the characters stuff but I've played
those games and they're literally four
four year old so just like collectathon
games aren't they yeah they're not very
well made either so you literally just
get killed all the time but you're
invincible like you have unlimited lives
so it's just context just look on but
you get a see bit from the movie Tom you
know I mean you get like a you know what
one of my favorite things from all the
Marvel movies is Ironman Supan up mmm
every movie they do a different suit up
right and on the lego game you can get
all the suits in every single time you
suit up he's got a different animation
I'm like wow this is really good this
year olds players like a hundred
characters that is pretty cool yeah a
lot of DC one coming out DC villains
yeah yesterday as well well Leno
Lindelof you can go through his
Instagram and see but I think the most
important part is here quote we have no
desire to adapt the 12 issues that mr.
Moore mr. Gibbins created
Higgens as well Lindy come on yeah
Higgins on another podcast 30 years ago
those issues are sacred ground and they
will not be retread nor created nor
reproduced nor rebooted they will
however be remixed because the baselines
the baselines in those familiar tracks
are just too good and would be fools not
to sample them Ohio he says it's sacred
ground but then that's like someone
saying are this this Greenbelt part of
land we're not allowed to build on it
but we're gonna put a [ __ ] car park
right beside it the topsoil will take
the nutrients will [ __ ] rip out but
the trees still there yeah it's um I
mean I don't mix sounds like such a
weird way yes cry Bertie I've never
heard that phrase used before either no
a remix of something yeah I'll get
outside of music yeah it's certainly no
more comic books yeah it's it's ah but
you know in the future we'll see who
knows maybe just don't call it Watchmen
like a it's called something even call
it like a reference to watch you know
something like that or a quote from it
or I don't know but yeah you know
they've got to have that uh that brand
recognition there so um just before we
get to the day's discussion of issue 5
of Doomsday Clock checking back in with
Eric Eric Ferguson he sends the greatest
emails you know I do a few podcasts and
receive emails from people and these are
my favorite things to read I have any so
shout out to Eric he was basically
responding to our um our issue 10 of the
original Watchmen Ronnie says hello
there only 43 minutes long and some
seconds of the podcast for issue then
your final pocket should be like Game of
Thrones episodes get longer and longer
as the finale looms you guys did an
excellent job breaking down the issue an
ageist reference in certain things we
spoke about you said supremely good
catch in Gerald Ford trippin as he walks
down the steps
this also showcases how well Alan Moore
is versed in American politics
even if Nixon had not resigned Alan
Moore is telling us here that Spiro
Agnew would have resigned due to
corruption who was Nixon's second in
chief interesting as astoria always
appreciate how well someone from another
country understands the minutiae of
American history in politics I must say
we do not give a [ __ ] about this kind of
thing with other countries this is in
contrast to Jeff Jones in Doomsday Clock
who reserves a rip refers to President
Robert
I thought you were gonna say resign
there Todd
okay remix in yeah absolutely no-fault
went into that it would have been better
if you refer to president Gary Hart or
Ted Kennedy instead yes true take
anything recall I then started
monitoring the panels and looking for
details in court one there was a
significant uniform change for the US
Army in the early 1980s as we switch
from the traditional green you see in
Vietnam war movie so the BDUs or wood
forest camouflage seaming the ever
classic heartbreak ridge the Germans
stole Kevlar we still use in service by
1983 and does not appear in the panels
of the first few pages of issue 10
showing US military personnel is
apparent in in 1986 they are wearing the
old green and old tin-pot helmets
another detail that I saw but was not
able to figure out was to painting to
the left of the stairwell and page eight
which we pointed out in in Karnak in
Aussies lair it surely has to be a
famous painting I did an image search of
Alexander the Great and ramasees on
Google and could not locate anything to
the left of the painting we can see all
the TV monitors Dave Gibbons shows us
that he has an excellent layout where
everything is it's not just hodgepodge
of whatever is convenient welcome for
and care went into preparing their
drawing
thanks for sharing about the 1959 Batman
comic book you got your wedding death
which we spoke about congratulations on
getting married so yeah I mean we've had
a bit of a break cause you've been on
your honeymoon which is crazy man yeah
so that's why this this episode so
delayed I've been away for two weeks in
Mexico a funny story
we were watching TV one night an advert
actually came on for the Watchmen movie
in Spanish I don't know why we were
watching Spanish TV but you know yeah
yeah and it's called the lost vigilantes
so it kind of loses some of the subtext
there yeah shame but you know it was a
nice just to know that watchman's always
there yeah yeah that is cool yeah
sometimes I just text you cups of coffee
out the blue that have like smiley faces
and them you know Watchmen we're living
in the watchman world eric says your
discussion on older comics reminded me
that it might be tough over there
finding old comics as a hobby in the
summer I go to garage sales looking for
the Holy Grail
old comics for sale by people who don't
know or care what they're selling
someone to get lucky finding 1960s x-men
for Fantastic Four for a buck or so it's
always an adventure take care and keep
up the good work Eric
Eric thank you so much again and Sarah
if anyone wants to get in touch of us
watching The Watchmen part at Jim calm
you know let us know what you think
especially of Doomsday Clock if you've
got any thoughts on this issue because
it didn't come out too far ago too long
ago so um it's thinking to issue five
death which is called there is no God
and I think about you but reading this I
was like what's going on again none of
the stories really kept in my head yeah
it's kind of very hitting misses
there's one bit in this that really
offended me okay um we'll get to it when
we do yeah I know I know because you've
told me but I also get would have
guessed definitely yeah yeah so I'm
basically the supplements on a brain
scan of Oz diamond Isis brain tumor and
it's quite a nice drawing that looks
almost all right this oh it's always
fantastic yeah I really like it it's
sort of a cold brutal reminder of what's
going on
and and I really do like this about the
Watchmen comics in general it's it's not
this bombastic oh now that you'd think
it's very real-world it's very gritty
and it's like when Hollywood announces a
sequel or something they'll always say
this one's gonna be darker and grittier
than the first one this this is sort of
the Empire Strikes Back of comic books
isn't it in the same way that Empire
Strikes Back is that Empire Strikes Back
of movies yeah yeah so yeah it's it's a
nice gritty of now it's not something
that you often see I quite liked it mmm
for an open now yeah I don't mind it I
like I like the way that the we're like
the tumor in his head sort of transforms
into the light that the doctors holding
yes yes I agree that is quite stylish
quite more esque
some of the dialogue slightly here I
mean it's I'm sorry at the dialogues
terrible yeah I'm sort of beating the
dead horse
we know the dialogues bad but it is the
sort of 12 years of Catholic school and
the hyper consciousness and sorry I
asked as an intellectual goes on a long
discussion is such a cliche in all media
and it's just not really that
interesting and I come
I had this feeling reading the whole
issue really we're issue five now they
should have legs there's no excuses and
it's just still little meandering for me
I tell you who's got legs and he's run
off Tom Jeff Jones he's [ __ ] runaway
hasn't he
what's going on then so yeah he's not
involved he's just left
yeah play nice left obviously it's
written all of Doomsday Clock already
yeah
but to be fair I can imagine it's a very
high demanding job especially like you
haven't run a massive company they're
sort of getting their ass kicked a bit
by marvel at the moment Warner Brothers
will be fuming about that Justice League
barely made its money back like look the
other day I've got Black Panther on
blu-ray
hey man I just was googling the cast and
it came up cinema listings so Justice
League barely made its money back Black
Panthers so popular that it's still at
the cinema while it's out on blu-ray
yeah you know I mean yeah yeah infinity
war just passed two billion dollars at
the box office so there's gonna be a lot
of pressure coming from above and he's
gotta [ __ ] live up to Watchmen he's
got little [ __ ] on podcasts like
animosity very good you know I mean yeah
he's just he's just resigned which is
fair enough Jim Lee's now gonna head up
DC again he's done it before
and so I know he can do a good job and
he's very comic orientated as well so
I'm sure I'll be fine it's in good hands
Jeff Jones the guy spearheading this
whole rebirth project yeah but you also
did new 52 as well oh yeah so it's not
like he's not seen it through something
through to the end and so it's gonna be
interesting to see what he writes but
yeah a kind of thing everything might
have just pushed him over the edge and
he probably just thought it's not worth
it from what I've seen he's taking a
writing job and so he's not the CEO of a
company so he probably just wants you
know he's made his money he's had a good
good five five I think when the new 52
was yeah that's roughly when he became
CEO and so yeah he's had he's had a good
inning um obviously Warner Brothers at
the moment [ __ ] nightmare and
everything's gonna [ __ ] a bit RTC
rebirths not going the way it's meant to
be there's loads of delays so he
probably just thought [ __ ] I'm off
yeah yeah we get a lot of context here
we get a lot of world building which I
mean I'm just thinking really off the
leftovers because the whole can see is
that two percent of the population
disappears and it does a really good job
in the pile of sort of feeding you stuff
through TV reports and conversation and
dialogue off this you know completely
abstract world this yeah you know a bit
more spoon-fed but again we're sort of
going over all topics here we've
established it's the artistic I think
what John's has done is try to focus
more on like the the sort
idioms and the similes between stuff
rather than than the actual plot like
you get this man is lucky as the opener
and we know he's got a brain tumor yeah
which is probably more agonizing over
death and fallen 20 stories and it's
it's hinted that dr. Manhattan saved him
by the comment you believe in God doc
you know I mean it's not it's not clever
and it's it's sort of more trying to be
wordplay and rather than actually
putting a foundation down and just being
outright this is what's happening which
is something that more could naturally
do he could handle both of those
spinning plates absolutely and just he
just can't no no he can't and I like I
like him lying on the bed at the bottom
of page one across as well it's a nice
thing that we get to see these he's
chained as well which is quite nice but
yeah the sort of the juxtaposition
there's the word of there is no God and
Superman's the only thing you can
believe in anymore
it's slightly on-the-nose as his
gas-mask is and I'd rather be chained to
the desk as he's pulling it out as well
I people say as a phrase I'd rather be
chained to a desk I've never see her own
a console yeah but I've never heard that
being said in parlance so I'm a little
bit confused by that and a bit confusing
as well the the the one of the cops
coined it looks like [ __ ] Reggie I
didn't even notice that maybe I'm just
being a bit yeah prejudice here but
point it does maybe Frank's is just
whenever people that draw yeah you do
it's dead when whenever I try to try and
draw anything I draw the same five faces
over and over is the worst for that like
I love him as a writer and he also draws
a lot of the image but all these
characters got the [ __ ] same it's
like yeah really annoying it's it's not
it's not interesting to see but yeah
Ozzy gets out as villains are want to do
and then pretty much escapes the
hospital as well in costume and we get
more context here death with the whole
metahumans global epidemic
yeah and that I'll do I do quite like
how when Ozzy's lying in bed it kind of
is the same layout as it was when
Superman was in bed in the first issue
oh yeah that's true yeah so that that's
quite nice exam again it's not
highlighting you know when was the
doctor's taught about near-death
experiences how dark and cold and gritty
this world is and and again that it's
it's just sort of feels to me like this
is kind of a wasted opportunity mm and I
do like when Ozzy man dies his escape
and how polite years yeah I'm asking
them for the keys for the cuff like we
know he's gonna beat them up maybe he'll
even kill them but it sort of signifies
how to me at least uh Diamond ice is the
good guy in his own head like he
murdered thousands of people that say
billions and to himself he's always sort
of the nicer person and it is quite a
little sort of thing that I do quite
like the way that he is trying to be
polite before he beats them up like the
same way that he was when he killed all
the people he's just always got the side
to him where he's he's being nice and I
do quite like how he goes and gets a bit
Bastas as well yeah davell cute back and
forth there may actually be some light
in this dark dark gritty world Tom
eventually so yeah and you know them
intruding as well in uniform and we
don't we don't get to see what's done if
he does in you know indeed hurt the guys
in the parlor but we assume not perhaps
and him going forward and yeah yeah then
we get this whole sequence with Lois
in the office we've it's Perry right
that's the guys name yeah boy and even
him saying call me mr. white when you're
yelling at me just bristles me slightly
the wrong way but I don't actually kind
of like this I kind of like him changing
it to be a metahuman assassin four
clicks he mentions as well which is so
2018 yeah and I actually have got a
little Theory from this page you know
Tom and but it's only something I've
noticed because that's but you know I
don't do my research so this is probably
being a to debunked and stuff but I've
only really realized it because they've
spelled it out and Superman's son in DC
rebirth continuity is called John hmm
how many Superboy now because he's named
after Jonathan Kent but I think in this
the the fact that they also say like the
say John's Godfather and I don't know if
that's highlighting to me that John is
dr. Manhattan in like the weird version
of him they spelling John like Jon
Osterman or neither hey yeah exactly so
she's Lois says is it too late to ask
someone else to be John's Godfather and
Clark goes ten years too late now when
rebirth first happened in rebirth issue
one they did say that ten years was
stolen from the DC characters so I don't
know if that ten years is hinting up
like that Johnny's dr. Manhattan yeah so
and obviously like it would explain how
he's got his powers but don't off it
what they will do it I read up no but
and it's just a little thing I noticed
when the two names being similar and
them saying ten years too late and we
get also a little bit of information on
another metahuman who Mikhail arcade in
a you know this idea of them
representing their borders and some sort
of international incident brewing I like
the fact that he was that it a he was
four killed in Chernobyl and that's
probably dumped before in comics but
it's quite an interesting origin yeah I
think they're trying to sort of in the
way that they watch me
had the nuclear threat yeah they're
trying to make this the metahuman threat
and it's all gonna come to a head at the
end yeah yeah I suppose so in the same
way that we had Redford like a
trump-like figure you know there is we
exist in these you know hectic times of
sort of interdisciplinary Russian
influence as well so it's kind of an
obvious enemy to go for and you know we
get word of the Superman theory as well
and what do you think his designs kind
of okay like the so ready flame
supervillains I didn't necessarily yeah
with him it reminds me a lot of
firestorm who's actually later in this
issue yeah and then I thought I just
thought it was a weird character choice
to have firestorm in later because if
this was like your first comic book
you'd probably think that the same
character so yeah just a very very
strange choice but obviously it hints
that he's gonna make everything burden
and there's a storm coming in the DC
Universe is dark and gritty now guys yep
yeah and we get some more of Rorschach
and Sally jubler not this sorry Saturn
girl and it's I don't know there's a lot
of subplots going on which are kind of
like kind of Doane but you know Jones is
doing such a kind of a good job of
mimicking Alan Moore he's not on that
level but he's doing a good job of
mimicry but I don't think he's anywhere
near as focused on the actual narrative
through line as we say yes isn't a bad
exchange from them but you think oh I
don't know what I almost think it's good
but I'm just saying it's like it's
passive what don't you like about it say
I was gonna say it's got the worst worst
worst worst ever play on words that I've
seen it's when the walk past a big
street light yeah the the street light
the angle of it it makes it look quite
big in Saturn girl goes we need a great
big light yeah I Alan Moore's turning in
his grave here I know he's not dead no I
know desi wish he was so they could bang
out more of these books but yeah just
horrendous
he probably sleeps in a grave but but I
I agree yeah yeah this is bad
yeah this is bad
I mean you think so here or saying it
like Harley Quinn need a great big light
and maybe she just said that it'd be
fine but yeah having nothing there and I
suppose as the inference as well of
what's-his-name Mothman you know and
that sort of idea you know I've just
thought what would have been better
you know how this entire issue all comes
to a head at the bat-signal hmm
if they had a said we need a great big
light and then they look in the sky and
you see the bat-signal off in the
distance
yeah and they could go there as well is
that what they do anyway a car remember
Tom this this issue is completely
forgettable Edie eighties eighties
forgettable and it is clunky and they
are setting up Lots is that what they do
a car emember
apprec-- what's my name again wait
you know what's this podcaster I think
my dying words will be [ __ ] a Fanueil
dusk
I literally do not care about this I
know that it's here just for the black
freighter idea none of its interesting I
know I always got on about it the
fade-out set in a similar era really
interesting stories this whole sequence
I I can't care about the only thing that
stood out to me that I thought was
interesting was he finds the accountants
you know a possible suspect in the
cupboard and the guy's name was Alistair
Tempest and tempers which I remember
from x-files means time yeah there was
an tempus fugit up in the episode was
get time flies so yeah maybe that's some
sort of little reference into it sort of
thing but um yeah so we have you know
mr. Fonda escaping Johnny fonder at 102
years old yeah I mean I don't quite like
this it's not bad it's new isn't it
I do like the idea of an old superhero
being in a nursing home and everyone
just sort of patronizing him and acting
like he's not important because we
pretty much do that in real life
yeah like World War two veterans get
shat on and then massively
underappreciated and I really think that
there's a nice metaphor there that we
sort of overlook things that people have
done because of senility and watching
him like have to take the bus because he
can't afford the train it's quite
heartbreaking you
and I kind of helped this guy get a
redemptive arc throughout this because
he was also [ __ ] on in rebirth issue one
mm-hmm and it'd just be nice to see him
finally get get something and we see
onto his desk books that may have
influenced his escape we see a headline
claiming the Green fires consumed all
American steel and Aladdin as well and
the wonderful lamp which he references
later as well yeah and I'm not quite
sure what that I want is the mythical
lands of something I'm not Lee yeah it's
kind of its kind of cut off there um
again the arts fantastic I think I love
the room I love the you know the long
drapes leading out on them looking down
the window and any thoughts on the
define your dusk sequence that we go
after that I really switched off for it
you know but to be fair John's I did it
for black freighter as well but yeah it
was just kind of just they're sort of
blocking the part I don't know what it
is with single issues I always just kind
of want to rush through them and sort of
think of them as a whole yeah um in
these bits kind of they're very plodding
they get in the way especially in a book
that that the main plot hasn't really
taken off yet no it's just kind of I
don't really know the context of it yet
I mean it might be with something that's
improved on a second read but from the
meantime it's just that under whites
there no no and you know even if black
Freya early on was harder to understand
harder to engage if he didn't understand
what you know the sort of the metaphor
they was for it was more inhabited this
sort of bloody Buccaneer writing style
that that was what was fun about it but
here Dawn's you know I'm thinking of you
know it always be a little bit of home
alone you know keep the change sort of
idea but none of it's that interesting
there's not like funny one-liners or
slang and just a bit time yeah and
something about the black freighter was
it was very visceral like watching him
stab sharks and the Eaton seagulls as
the blood drips down his mouth it's
those images sort of do stick in your
mind where is this like I don't know
it's just noise in the background I know
it's meant have been noise in the
background but it just is eating me
Oh hiya tea at the page nine which is
essentially about mr. fonder commuting
to the factory if you look at the top
left with the queue of people there's
like a kid on the look at the bottom
right of that panel it's like a kid
lying on the floor
I don't really know yes I don't know
that has any importance or anything but
I just noticed that I was kind of
scaring the scaring the crowd saves
anyone there as well but yeah he's a bit
delusional you know mention his lamp
doesn't have enough money and I guess
it's painting a picture as well of the
sort of the public at large they are
quite testy aren't they I think normally
if an old man was confused you'd sort of
maybe you wouldn't help him but you
wouldn't be aggressive but this guy just
shouts at him tell him to take the bus
yeah it's just weird but it did quite
like it it's a nice creative thing that
John's has done in the same way that
Mothman had had his scene in the insane
asylum and see nice that John's was
taking the time to do this and it is to
me one of the highlights of the book in
the same way that the Mothman
section was I wish it was more like that
if it was set all in like in old
people's home or an insane asylum and it
was just about two people escaping I
would have loved it mmm but there's just
so much extra noise that doesn't need to
be here it's very convoluted and you're
constantly jumping back and forward
between plot like Watchmen when you go
back and read it is where you've done
you realize that these single issues are
very focused so you have a dr. Manhattan
origin story you have a Rorschach origin
story you have an issue where it's just
focused on Dan and Laurie you've got an
issue it's just about Laurie and dr.
Manhattan on Mars debating you know the
meaning of life it's very focused
whereas this is just jumping back and
forth between plot lines and because of
that it feels very jumbled and then into
that mix you throw in the [ __ ]
black-and-white TV show Cory remember
the name of yeah what's my name again
yeah you're completely right and even
the the sort of the sequencing between
scenes as well it lacks that kind of you
know that that continuity that
smoothness we move on and we get Ozzie
meeting Batman yeah which
I did think was a nice little scene
Batman this time sort of the spinning
villain in the chair it sort of reminds
me a bit of James Bond and when he's
sitting reading the journal it's really
well drawn and it's beautifully blacked
out and I do think it's was there is the
most Samba meeting thus far it does work
for me but it gets completely derail
later and which I'll talk about and it
once again the Batman characterization
in this book just doesn't sense it's so
great yeah I do like him silhouetted in
Archie's eye and yeah not sure if it's a
callback to when we see you know when
chameleons rapes miss Jupiter and you
see in Moloch's death right maybe it is
maybe it's just him in front of the eye
there but but yeah I agree and I think
the Dauntless is called as well and I
like how Bubastis is you don't you kind
of see a little tinge of fur in the
glimmer but you don't really see much
beyond that and we get on the next page
page 11 something Watchmen the bread and
butter of Watchmen death the nine panel
grid it's our only encounter with
comedian and yeah it's not it's not bad
I don't mind this a little bit it's a
bit of juxtaposition here Tom it is and
because comedians basically
investigating a body of the guy that's
been murdered at two policemen walk in
he just goes I'll give you two options
lads one is that I'll slit your throat
in the other that is I'll just walk out
em and they just let them walk out and
it's sort of a nice juxtaposition on the
way that comedian sort of respected by
two guards that run in and try and stop
him whereas as human dies before I had
to take one of them hostage and beat the
other one up and it just showcases how
much more intimidating the comedian is
and because they just let him walk out
and it's very sort of more humor on this
section yet there's a dark dark dark
gritty side to it well yeah I mean
there's someone with their hands
you know sliced off their wrists it's so
dark and gritty down yeah it is and I
like how he takes one of the cigars from
his part
here's one the colorings excellent the
the bright flashlight you know the heat
of the lighter on his face
the neon of the jukebox curving rounds
well great but is it me or does
chameleons have a little little prance
in his step as he leaves the bar
yeah it's quite nice yeah and obviously
he's investigating a murder by the mime
and marionette so it is good how they
tie into it them on the next page I have
just noticed that like literally every
page is dealing with a different
character yeah yeah yeah it is jumping
it is jumping from plotline to plotline
really just with stupid wordplay
and but anyway we'll continue with there
you're right you've got six plot loins
in 11 pages yeah that's crazy isn't race
that's two that good there's not like I
can't wait to get back to this one
they're all like yeah whenever yeah yeah
they're killing more people they're
looking for the Joker money isn't
important to them I see this thing's I'm
liking this things are hating so nothing
to think of myself as you said fairly
before if more did this would you hate
on it and I don't know
so then saying your bills don't have
Nixon on them is yeah cool I like I like
that yeah I don't like that there's a
bill hovering in the third panel so we
can see what they're saying I don't
think that's necessary
yeah I do like the next in comment to be
honest because it does sort of speak to
Nixon's ego um especially in the
Watchmen universe where he's pretty much
given unlimited power like you do wonder
if someone like that had have been
president and if that was the reason for
the nuclear escalation like I always
loved how the comedian originally
thought that the world would have gone
mad if America had a bluster Vietnam and
which is what of course what happened to
us in our reality and which might have
forced us to sort of look at ourselves
and stop being bullies and so the fact
that America won the Vietnam War in the
Watchmen universe it gave this guy like
Nixon it just gave him so much power
that you can see why the world did
escalate to like being on the brink of
nuclear war
so I do like the the mention of Nixon
here and the fact that he's he's so
egotistical that he's put himself on the
money yet the current president not only
the country exactly yeah so it's a nice
touch for me yeah yeah like that Wow
being kinda nice yes or than a none
offensive yeah so you know they continue
to hunt the Joker we kind of know where
this is going and the meeting of the lie
and um I guess it happens a lot in
Batman comics I'm not seeing it myself
but I like the bat-signal on the clouds
yeah it's really nice it doesn't
actually happen it's not often drawn
like that mm-hm sort of very pushed up
against the clouds and it's got so much
texture to it whereas normally it's just
quite flat yeah it's nice seeing it
drawn like that to be honest yeah yeah
it's nice is the bulge and then you know
corresponding with you know that the
logo against his own chest and the
police sorry I mean Batman is always
[ __ ] getting hunted by law
enforcement it seems inevitably so and
they barrel off in Archie as they're
being assaulted and I do quite like the
splash panel at the pet bottom page 14
we've I don't know he's fake Batman's
face is got a weird though he looks kind
of pouty I don't quite know how to
explain it and you can see the the the
ferris wheel they smashed through in the
back as well yeah behind them like again
the art is great like I really you know
I have to say Gary Franks as a does a
great job here
and what do you think about Rorschach
and bats which is probably the longest
secrets between two characters we get in
the you know see Ozzy sorry yeah going
through and you know sort of debating
their own merits who they are yeah and I
think it's quite nice how it's set to
the backdrop of the protests and we're
like at the in issue one people are
protesting against Ozymandias and they
were coming to rip them down in the same
way that now people are protesting
against Batman and I don't know exactly
what it's signifying maybe maybe it's
just sort of a metaphor for taking down
the corporate power that appears to be
evil
and but I can't really see why anyone
would
ever want Batman arrested by the police
like he's a vigilante but he saves the
city all the time he never kills never
harms innocents so don't exactly know
why people would be after him like
people love Tommy Robinson and he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but the hey Batman I
don't get it I don't get it Tom mmm no
you don't look Tommy Robinson do you I
don't
well I don't but you love Doomsday Clock
now Tommy Robinson is the Doomsday Clock
oh why is that
oh isn't it Eric Ferguson's gonna be
like Who's Tommy Robinson but give him a
look of Eric you're not gonna you're not
gonna approve of him on sir and and we
get some more as you mentioned here's
firestorm as well and you know flip them
back and forth the argument between all
these created beings or are they in fact
you know natural occurrences now deaf
I'm guessing what you mentioned prior
the scene that really pissed you off is
the ED bottom of this page 14 I don't
know why you're getting it Tom you
you've been said at the start of the
video that I told you which one it was
dramatic effect but you've completely
lost all the mystique yeah so to me just
the Isis beheading just seemed really
out of place um it's basically what
happens is it shows jihadi john' with a
hostage in an orange t-shirt you know
something that's kind of being burned in
your head the last couple of years um
and it is it's a nice callback that they
use Jack Ryder who's a famous journalist
in the Batman comics but okay
just as a scenario it seems too soon I
these were actual the headings that
happened and the fact that they've sort
of used it to deliver a punch line it's
quite distasteful for me like I rarely
do get offended by stuff but I don't
know this just kind of rubbed me up the
wrong way I mean they could have used a
million different ways to showcase a
superhero which in this case is Black
Adam and saving people and it just seems
a bit strange like this is a real
terrorist attack and it's a very very
very brutal one it would it's and it
only happened a couple years ago it
would be like a recrea
you know like the Manchester bombings or
something yes a mother tragedy and and
using that to show what would happen if
like a superhero was there like I'm I
probably shouldn't have even mentioned
the Manchester Bauman's there because I
know that you know it's quite recent and
I really apologize if anyone know so
takes out a heart but that well even
that reaction there that I've just had
it myself again sort of just highlights
how bad it is to use that and like I'm I
just don't get why Jones is using this
and what is essentially just a comic
book like can you imagine if you knew
one of the people who've been beheaded
and you just reading through this comic
and you get at this point you'd be
fuming and then we do it yeah and we do
talk a lot about things like 9/11 and
JFK and how these real events of and
real tragedies they've almost become
fictionalized due to their overuse and
stories if this is just a step too far
for me personally what do you think on
it yeah you offended by all I wasn't
offended but I was surprised and I
totally see where you come from and I do
think it's slightly unnecessary
I guess it's making reference explicitly
in the fact that he's a journalist to
James Foley who was one of the exactly
famous passings yeah so which was 2014
so yeah not long ago told about four
years ago and is it something a bit a
bit rah-rah about it as well a bit like
soup heroes beheading terrorists and it
just feel and the fact that his head
sort of fleeing cross and he's being
called a [ __ ] and all this and
it I don't know yet it's a little gauche
yeah for me personally it's not Isis of
course it's some kali-yuga and we get
our first mention of you know completely
fictionalized completely not trying to
be Qatar or Iran AK and AK I know that's
that's been around for years Tom Oh has
it has it yeah black Adams from a nation
called contact they sort of police
themselves okay yeah but yeah that's
been that's been in comics for decades
in decades and what we're seeing get
smashed eventually of course your riots
are continuing and you
what do you think of Batman's assessment
of Ozzie of being a victim of hero
syndrome well yeah it's quite weird
because I've watched a lot of
psychological documentaries on like the
the psyche of Batman and and it's
something that Batman's often accused of
as well they talk about how basically
your human dies caused this problem and
swooped in and saved the day and in the
same way that they talk about how batman
often creates a lot of his villains he's
responsible for the escalation of masked
villains in gotham oni but he sort of
the remedy for it and the US government
as well as always like accused of hero
syndrome where they go and invade places
like iraq that like roof doing fine on
their own and just sort of try and pick
themselves out as Patriots with you know
I I'm not if if anyone was involved in
that war
I'm not saying that you you're not a
hero or anything are trying to dismay
that it's just what people often do say
of the US government and and once it's
tuned as human dies his case it's it's
difficult to confirm whether the other
ones are mainly to me because Batman was
a response to the crime level in Gotham
in the same way that you know the
invasion of Iraq was a response to 9/11
again it's very 9/11 centric this
episode isn't it yeah we learn about the
immediate withdrawal of all troops from
the Middle East and yeah geopolitically
you know things are changing certainly
for the worst and Lex is here Lex is
back speeding to Lois and Lex has a
theory about the Superman theory right
yeah and I wonder though there's a
little mention here about how someone
shot people wearing a Superman armband
yeah and I wonder if this is like a hint
at Batman V Superman because it's a
scene in that where there's a nightmare
sequence where soldiers and that where's
Superman armbands but yeah I don't know
but it's all highlights how people often
commit horrendous acts in the name of
God and religion to me at least and they
kind of give it a
give it a motive when you don't know
even if it's true or not in the end the
person the god or in this case Superman
you've never intended for this to happen
but someone's committed this atrocity in
his name know this song there's so much
co-opting of history going on in this
comic like we said with the James Foley
stuff and I bet I bet in the crowd in
the next color of issue someone will
have a placard that says met human lives
matter yeah you know what I mean that's
gonna be there isn't it just gonna be
yeah I've got we're no longer well we
know we no longer want it be where we're
not want it is a line here Tommy I
wonder if that's why Jeff Jones left you
did this
Tom Louise yeah I we see Superman as
well staring down dead saddest mean it's
everyone's least favorite depiction of
Superman just moping around in the sky
looking sad they did it in Superman
Returns and everyone hated it and they
did it in Batman V Superman and everyone
[ __ ] a there was just I guess with
this whole comic I was hoping for
something a bit grander in scale but
it's still very intimate and the
characters are starting to converge on
each of a somewhat and you know I think
it kicks up a little bit as we're
getting into the final act as it were
but you just think that a lot this
could've been streamlined right yeah
definitely there's a lot of filler here
and whilst Watchmen could be argued
that's got a lot of filler it's more
world-building yeah whereas this just
seems like stuffs happening and we get a
old man Thunder going for the rain on
the last stop and he's warned by the
driver this isn't the best neighborhood
apparently the drummer who has an odd
silhouette the nose a sort of pig nose I
don't know if that's some [ __ ]
obscure Batman character or maybe it's
just no one in particular
yeah and he's heading in to the All
American steel idea and what do you
think of this sequence then him sort of
being accosted yeah so it's quite well
drawn and it's basically schmuck rats or
crackheads as they're known in America
and I love the way that Frank's drawn
them you probably used himself as a
mirror after having his stay up all
night drawing this [ __ ] but you know
they're really well drawn and and I do
like how Captain Thunder sort of comes
in at this point as well because earlier
they they say that there's a mystery
that someone who created them at humans
for the government was themselves once a
member of the Justice League some guess
and that you know captain thunders
probably got something to do with that
especially because it cuts right to him
and they've got absolutely no salty and
they spell out for you ever again what
do you think of this schmuck Rus yeah I
think they're drawn well um give me a
wallet for I poke your eyes out doesn't
really read well to me I think something
bear could have been written there and
yeah it's not bad I mean he's drawn by
some sort of sense of fate clearly to
this idea and he's being tested as he
enters and we get more stuff from Ozzie
and bats as well your world was worse
off than mine and I quite like this sort
of philosophical arguing that they go
through as well and you're Batman not
wanting to hurt the police of course
yeah I don't like it because I think it
just makes Batman look like an idiot
right like if you just read this book
he's come to the conclusion that human
dies as a bad guy if he wanted to take
him down he would have done it at the
fairground and not in the air like the
run away cuz two policemen showed up are
you stupid Batman wouldn't give a [ __ ]
mate he was trained by the League of
Assassins do you think he cares about
two policemen show no he would have just
taken the policemen out instead now he's
making them he's destroying half of
downtown because he's in the air
fighting in Archie it's just I didn't
feel that the fire that everyone's gonna
hate him cuz he's destroying all this
[ __ ] you would have just arrested him
Tom yeah back at the fairground he knew
he didn't like the lad I don't know
what's going on here no no and we get a
mime and marionette on the rooftop
following the light and we hear some of
the stuff that he did as well weaning
the world of gasoline and oil
curing famine negotiating nuclear
disarmament Bob see what was that all
for and we see um some clips I guess
it's within arching this TV screen of
black adam black adam i know his name
who is this going in DC mythos he says
Shazam villain right ma'am so he's got
the same pair of shoes on
he's actually just an old man and very
very old but he said Shazam
he got transformed in this black adam
character and he rules the nation of
khandaq and he's the rocks got cast ISM
yeah yeah in in one of the movies that
DC's never gonna make they've got the
the DEA just announced a different movie
every week Tom it's doing my head in
they've never made them isn't Todd
Phillips doing like a joker or Regina's
and they're doing - Joker movies right
Marvel announced 20 movies do you know
how many they didn't make I'm guessing
zero you're right yeah Inhumans didn't
get a theatrical release they're still
made it complem DC of announced 38 that
made 5 it's ridiculous every week
they're announcing something it's got
the point where I'm just MAME who likes
DC I just text him every time the
announcer like this isn't getting made
every [ __ ] week anyway Black Adam the
rock look out for it I said it before DC
you can turn your fortunes around if you
give Darren Aronofsky an all-star
Superman script yeah or someone like
that maybe like Darren and offski but
someone like that it's like really
thinks you're awesome on there just need
to stop copying Marvel like Justice
League
they're made so many changes in it and
spent so much money because they were
just constantly like second-guessing
themselves mmm and they probably had
quite a good script um but they just got
no faith they've got no faith Batman's
falling out the old man's finding the
the lantern I mean what do you make of
this like him reading a headline that
there's green smoke him getting a coach
and then just finding it on a plinth
yeah it's a bit stupid and apart it's
one of them things I didn't really know
us at the time but now you mentioned it
yeah maybe I want to say some light will
be shared but it already chewed it like
you shouldn't feel that way shouldn't
you didn't want that to go further into
the shoe and the back grapple comes into
play starts back key component right
yeah and yep so you sort of like him
sort of swinging above the aching arms
and okay sequences here the old man gets
the lantern what does he want the
lanterns you think it's a Green Lantern
in it yeah no I know but like what is it
to him like what you know because he
used to be in the Justice League can
they use thunder they use Atlanta
probably I think people can just put on
the ring and just wield the power right
they can and I'm saying I think I know
they can't come I've seen it um so yeah
it's it's it's nice I like it I don't
know it's gonna go it's a bit intriguing
it's called my ending and I mean I'm
sure you would know it yourself and
everyone reading but I quite like the
lands have being held above and very
similar to Hollis Mason with the statue
yeah yeah it did like that cute it's
really nice yeah yeah that's nice that's
nice that's all I like that logically
and yeah the rescued by Rorschach and
you know Miss Ann and I quite like don't
worry they were all going to overdose
tonight anyway which yeah it's a really
a consolation but it's kind of a kind of
a funny line here and we end with things
coming together I suppose and I think
issue six should be a bit more
interesting we get the Joker right the
end as well see I didn't think that was
interesting
no I think it was just it ends on a
cliffhanger yeah it's got Batman caught
by the writers in the Joker showing up
but that doesn't really do anything for
me just sort of there mmm it is sort of
a deus ex machina it's a it's a cheap
way to get you to come back next time to
see what happens
yeah she's now really danke no no I mean
probably shouldn't be doing a podcast
about it Tom
I'm sure the listeners are probably
would much rather have someone who does
care but I just it's beat me Tom you
know what but you know when it killed me
Tom was when they were looking at this
picture of Black Adam upside down and
the dialogue balloon said I've turned
the world upside down
and that's the bit that was just a bit
that killed it
yeah yeah you need these inferences
these mirroring zhh to be a certain
level of debt for not to be just
completely shallow like that because
then they're not fun to find out but
yeah that one is terrible I agree so and
then Batman in a heap you know pretty
yeah it's not that tense what's gonna
happen we have them off again flying
into the lanterns flame and a quote from
the American playwright Eugene O'Neill
when men make God's there is no God yeah
which is a nice quote but it's been
Google done it Tom yes it has and we get
the back matter is better than the issue
itself I genuinely think the design you
yeah it's cool yes I already like this
and I love the fact that this is sticker
on the bottom right the good life home
for the elderly roads being delivered
and of course look at the day it's a
year in the future Oh May 30 of 2019 and
we're learning about you know the the
metahuman menace and I read I didn't
read it but I went through the
Multiversity Grant Morrison Wow I've
just got that again I bought it years
ago yeah and when it was quite cheap in
there I sold it I don't know why looking
back cuz I even I even enjoyed it at the
time yeah I didn't really read the story
but in the middle of it there is a goal
a watchman there was a going to all the
planets and I just never see we always
got always going on about how much I
love grandmas imagination it's so
[ __ ] cool all these heroes and all
these twists on the areas and some of
them are like you know the Batman from
the Future universe and some of them are
really weird universities I'm gonna like
1920 steampunk which is really fun to
see and we sort of get this here with
the metahuman arms race
and I didn't like this you know we get
the France the heroes I think I said to
you before there's one called the fief
of arts which I really want to learn
about what he's going for but yeah its
John's flexing its creative muscles and
I've got a lot of respect I think if I
was given this and had to come up with
cool names and ideas I would struggle to
match him yeah definitely it's quite
nice it's a nice little guy I do like
stuff like this and because I would
probably read it if it was in a magazine
anyway yeah so it's not it's a nice
addition to the course going back to my
University did you read Pax Americana I
didn't know that is like a standalone
Watchmen remake by Grant Morrison and
it's just one issue but you pretty much
remakes Watchmen and but he does it with
the Charlton characters mm-hmm really
really one of the best standalone issues
that I've ever read of anything and
really recommend you check so now yeah
they definitely will that's really good
so yeah for those not aware we're sort
of learning about the metahumans in
America but then crucially the ones
overseas so even India Britain they have
nice ink over there including good diver
looking-glass Ridge mrs. mrs. Hyde which
you can kind of in picture and yeah I
really like this I this probably one of
my favorite things I've seen in Doomsday
Clock the whole series so far yeah
definitely and it's really well drawn
it's I mean some of the covers on this
you could use is like a farm background
they're really good yeah yeah yeah yeah
but not my phone background Tom cause
it's of me and my wife and it will never
change don't try and change it Israel
have their own group as well which were
learning about sera and got Gollum which
is quite cool because it's very Jewish
fing The Golem as the idea I think in
mythology it's or the creature that's
collected of all the sadness you've
strewn in the world nowadays so who
knows how many these characters are
actually gonna meet but hopefully quite
a few because I don't know that watching
one of DC characters are it boring at
the moment so maybe they confer a few
interesting ones in there and we close
with a secrets on on Khandaq and Black
Adam so clearly the pieces are in place
for the opening issues right the next
issues yeah definitely
looking forward and our informants times
yeah yeah let's have a look actually
when that's gonna be released I think
it's I think it literally is like August
or some [ __ ] yeah well why are you doing
that Tom I'm gonna read out some of the
comments from the last Doomsday Clock so
Josh whoa cool he said in terms of my
interest in Doomsday Clock I'm more
interested in the possibility of them
using Doomsday Clock to bring back
characters that we haven't seen in DC
for a while for me hopefully the
character of Vic's age and the question
will come back chase so how to please
please send it better like I'd love it
if someone sent in a really offensive
username I miss reading their mouth and
satin girl is a member of the Legion of
super-heroes along with Brainiac 5 and
Monell and apparently Byron walking back
into the fire has something to do with
before Watchmen but again he's a moth
drawn to the flame and the fook implies
that Byron would fly away repeatedly and
never get caught with a Reggie as his
friend it makes sense as he'd always
have someone to let him in but I don't
know what type of security a mental
hospital will have Byron also says he's
never been much of a fighter but knew
enough which could be why he is trained
his training was so effective because
new Rorschach says at the beginning that
he was never of items a fighter himself
then he goes on to say this was by far
my favorite issue of the series why is
it a bad thing that they use an entire
issue to explore the new Rorschach story
we'll find out about Veidt in the
comedian and Superman soon enough jesus
[ __ ] christ that's how he ends it Tom
yeah yeah yeah it's or dude derailed it
for a slowly but I think in book
hardback form maybe it wouldn't be you
know the biggest crime yeah which they
needed to me right I just read comics
pretty much as volumes yeah I hate this
staggered release whenever I do decide
to pick up stuff issue by issue it
always does my head in that I've gotta
wait a month um and I do kind of wish
that one day that just like release it
like the way that they did their Killing
Joke or
and Batman Arkham Asylum by Grant
Morrison they just released it as a
complete package so and I really just
wish they would do that once in a while
just something like this even if it was
30 quid Tom I'd still buy yeah yeah it
would be nice I mean but instead I'm
having to steal it off the internet
every month so so yeah and it seems that
F issue six he's gonna come out August
29th pretty much into the summer and
we're recording this on the 14th of June
so you know we got [ __ ] longer have
you seen the cover of the issue six no
what is it it's quite it's actually
probably the best cover so far it's it's
like describe it because the listeners
won't be able to see okay this is is
marionette as an actual marionette
puppet with lots of other characters as
sort of cartoony puppets interestingly
hanging next to her is Hollis Mason here
a night owl and you can also see a
Richard Nixon doll and a grim reaper
darkness of which behind her but the
mainly to recognizable ones are yeah
mariner and Hollis Mason they're so
intriguing apparently here oh yeah yeah
it's quite definitely recommend people
google and it's really nice yeah it's
quite it's quite good and just a little
boy oh the little boy line here is
saying Geoff Johns Gary Frank could do
this groundbreaking event as the mine
and my mum marry me not very
groundbreaking when it's a remake of
something else completely unoriginal
event as my marionette takes center
stage and doom stop Doomsday Clock
issues six hmm so it's coming it's
coming people are you looking forward to
the moment marionette taking center
stage do a lot like Avenue a lot to
convince me that they've been worthwhile
but not even [ __ ] halfway through
like there's another six issues after
number six so it's gonna be it's gonna
be difficult but as ever we are here so
you know subscribe to the podcast
subscribe to the channel you can take a
bit of a break deaf I know so the viral
smashes have slowed right not really
they're not as big as the were but I
knew that would happen because the
movies aren't as big as there were
either yeah like Jurassic world I did a
video on that the other week because it
came out over here it's not been
released like in the US or anything so I
knew it wasn't good
you crazy but you know it might pick up
Tom you might see me bragging about my
views on a tweet very soon I might be
texting you like I used to when I was
dead excited about gone viral
but yeah the movies that there's not
really anything coming out for it the
rest of the year so I'm just gonna have
to go back to my Netflix movies Tom do
it just get the Netflix movie end and
explained yeah but I've just watched it
on Netflix no we you need the end and
explain here but it was really simple
and straightforward look click the video
well subscribe to Deb's channel
subscribe to us on iTunes as well I
think so you say enough slow down Tom
I've just checked my channel I've had
200,000 views in the last month
Wow so it's doing better than this buddy
podcast it is it is casting bringing in
them 200,000 views Tom I tell you that
it's not it's not you know we've got AB
real brutally honest to our listener
here shower Eric but yeah if you want to
email us in as well get in touch with us
watching them watch one part @ gmail.com
yeah we will be back for issue 11 of
watchman very soon I can't believe
almost done with that but def any any
closing thoughts no if God is a DJ life
isn't written well yeah this has been
Tom and you know thank you as always for
listening guys so yeah this has been
what I even say at the end they probably
remember us and it's okay for me right
from me yeah it's a good night from Quay
there we go that was terrible that one
[Music]